Hello boys and girls McGuane gremlins.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
If you're looking for perhaps some type of high brow intellectual long form
conversation,
you might want to go to tim.blog/podcast for one of my other long form
interviews.
Don't sell us short dude,
come on.
Hold on.
Kevin,
I haven't introduced yet,
but for those of you who enjoy the,
the random helter skelter,
is that a right word?
Yeah,
I think it is nature.
Well,
I'm going to run with it of the random show,
which we haven't had an episode of for a very,
very long time and does a conversation between yours truly and my good friend,
uh,
Kevin Rose number one on the Tim Ferriss show.
That's true.
You were guest number one,
the very first episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
And actually it's in my linkedin bio now.
That's my claim to fame.
It's in your Google plus bio and we have not done random show for a long time,
but I'll let you do if you want to do an introduction of the random show we need
to.
And even know what episode we're on.
Like for those that view they have heard the random,
she'll be four.
I think we've done probably if I had to guess I'd say maybe 25 episodes,
something like that.
25 to seven episodes.
So episode 27 let's call it episode 27 and Kevin,
for people who don't know you,
what's your story?
What would you like people to know about you?
What's the biggest question?
The speaker bio version of Kevin Rose?
I don't even know these days.
Uh,
no seriously.
Um,
I would say that I've been a longtime Internet entrepreneur.
I probably am best known for creating these social news website.
Dig Back in 2004,
um,
that grew to become a pretty big entity,
for a number of years.
And then I was at Google as an investor and now I'm at true ventures as an
investor.
Tim,
you and I probably co-invested in maybe a dozen or so angel deals.
Yeah,
at least Facebook together,
I think Twitter together,
Twitter together,
blue bottle coffee together,
a bunch of them.
Side Note.
You remember how ridiculed we all were when the consortium of techies and
non-techies invested in blue bottle coffee.
Do you remember how much shit we got on the Internet for that?
Absolutely.
They're like,
why would blue bottle need to raise money and,
but it's done.
Okay.
It had,
it had a great exit here just about a month ago.
It has done all right.
It was a what was a majority stake acquisition by Nestle for 700 million or so.
So it worked out.
Yeah,
it worked out.
So you've done very well as an investor,
you are obsessed with many things Japanese.
Yeah.
Who you have a new obsession,
it seems every few weeks.
And uh,
do you have anything new to add?
Actually,
you know what,
I want that stuff.
I want to hear about the fast mimicking diet because this is something I thought
I would have put money on.
You never sticking with the fast moving diet and maybe you can explain for
people what that,
but you've actually now done a number of scheduled five day.
Yeah,
that's great.
That's fine.
FMD.
So I'll,
I'll start back by saying that probably the reason why,
Tim,
you and I are friends.
I met you when you were launching your first book,
um,
on your boat party that you did.
You rented out a warship,
the San Francisco Bay and the ss Jeremiah where they recorded a lot of the
boiler room audio for the James Cameron movie titanic.
Oh,
crazy.
In fact,
that's awesome.
But um,
yeah,
we hit it off because we both love all kinds of,
of this idea of lifelong learning I think has been a theme that you and I both
enjoy.
And um,
you know,
I've certainly got really into biohacking in the last couple of years.
I've watched from afar.
Um,
you poke and prod yourself and squirt all kinds of different juices out of your
elbow.
You know,
this requires a little bit of explanation.
So this is so gross.
All right.
But now I have to explain it.
So I had a botched PRP injection,
which is platelet rich plasma injection in my right elbow.
And people can look up PRP.
It actually has some fantastic applications,
but there was a botched injection which pushed effectively subcutaneous bacteria
into the elbow capsule itself.
And it turned into this horrible infection that required a bright moment and
surgery and so on.
But Kevin being the good friend that he is,
came to visit me in the Er when I was having the,
uh,
I'm not sure if you'd call it synovial fluid,
the infection flu is the pos drained out of your ass,
drained out of my elbow with this gigantic syringe and uh,
being the mature adult that I am,
I thought it'd be funny to take this Turkey based or worth of elbow fluid out of
the,
the sharps container and squirt it at Kevin who is in the room.
I'm not proud of it,
but I don't regret it either.
So yes,
you've seen me do a lot,
uh,
and make a lot of short term decisions that haven't turned out very well in the
world of biohacking.
It's always entertaining though.
Got To say I had a lot of fun doing stupid shit together.
Um,
but yeah,
speaking of,
of,
well probably not that dumb these days,
but,
uh,
fasting.
So I got into fascinating,
um,
here probably about three years ago,
two to three years ago,
um,
I started fasting at zero,
which is a,
a free,
fascinating tracker.
Um,
and so that,
uh,
has really kind of blown up and taken off.
Um,
but then I started hearing about,
um,
the research from Delta Doctor Valter Longo.
And so,
um,
we actually was from a friend of mine,
uh,
you know,
Mike Mays or a mutual friend of ours and Mike was diagnosed with stage four
cancer.
Um,
he went into chemotherapy treatment and he was one of the guys that said,
I'm just not going to,
you know,
um,
just take what they gave me,
but I'm going to go out and do my own research and see what else I can be doing
to help fight this in,
beat this down.
And one of the things that came up was this idea of doing these five day FMDs
and the FMD stands for fasting,
the medic diet.
And the idea is that,
um,
compliance of doing a standard five day fast is relatively low because it's,
it's an extremely difficult thing to do.
Um,
uh,
Tim,
have you ever done a five day water?
Only fast.
Have you tried?
Yeah,
I've done five,
seven and 10 day.
Okay.
So I've done a five day water only and I will tell you,
it is absolutely brutal.
I don't know what your experience was,
but like I had a really difficult time sleeping.
Yeah.
There's a,
I believe it's a coal energic effect that leads you to have rapid heartbeat
quite often.
Yes.
When you were trying to sleep,
it's not pleasant.
So you'll be arrested and you'll lay down in bed and you're,
you'll feel like you just ran a hundred meter sprint.
Uh,
in terms of heartbeat,
it's very unpleasant.
It's kind of scary you like,
and,
and I get those.
I'm also one of those people that,
um,
get those,
uh,
I get this little war early heartbeats,
you know,
where you'd like feel like your,
your heart,
like kind of skip a beat a little bit.
They're completely benign.
And I've had it looked at and everything's fine,
but I get those every once in a while.
And those are those come more frequently when I'm in a fasted state.
So long story short,
Mike does his five day fast.
Um,
he beats back cancer.
He's in full remission,
which is awesome.
Um,
but the idea with the,
the five day fast is that I interrupt you one more time.
The S and I think this,
I don't think Mike would mind this,
but I remember you and I when we were talking about this and he,
did he do five or three?
I can't recall.
Sorry.
You're right.
He did three.
She did three.
But just,
just for those who are curious.
So I've had conversations with Dominic D'Agostino before on this podcast,
very well published researcher.
And I was first introduced to the possibility that fasting prior to
chemotherapy,
uh,
I believe and radiation could be either a,
has the potential to increase the resilience of normal cells while increasing
the susceptibility or weakness of cancer cells to facilitate this type of
treatment,
but also to decrease the side effects that are commonly experienced.
And so Mike,
to my understanding would do say a three day fast before a session and while the
other people in his cohort were laid out on the,
on the couch or in bed the next day,
he'd be running a 10 mile training run,
which is just insane.
Which is nuts.
Yeah.
And,
and so he originally,
and when he got turned on to this,
um,
research by Doctor Longo is,
he showed me this youtube video where they were giving rats chemotherapy and the
one,
the rats that were fast,
they were just like running around the cage.
It looked like normal healthy rats and the ones that didn't fast where just like
you said,
like on their side,
all beat up and in a horrible state.
And that's exactly what Mike experienced.
And Yeah,
the idea is that I'm on the making the chemotherapy more effective is that,
you know,
you're depriving yourselves of the cancer cells have some nutrients,
certainly sugar,
less glucose,
and it makes them more susceptible to the chemotherapy treatments and the chemo
therapy is that much more effective.
So,
you know,
obviously we can't say for certain whether that's what put them into remission,
but he's really happy that it did work and he is in remission and the evidence
looks pretty compelling,
um,
in humans.
Um,
and so they're also a extending this whole protocol to healthy individuals as a
way to potentially prevent cancer from even forming in the first place.
So I was turned on to,
um,
doctor Valter Longo,
his new book,
the longevity diet,
and I had him on my podcast.
If you've seen this book yet.
I have seen that.
Yeah.
I haven't read it,
but I have seen it.
Yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
So the,
there's a whole chapter on his FMD protocol in which you need to do to the,
do these five day fast.
And so I guess getting into what it actually is.
So how it differs from a water only fast is that you do have calories,
so you have around 700 or so calories per day.
Um,
some people say that sounds like a lot.
Some people say it sounds like a little,
it's actually not that much food.
It's like a handful of small soups and some crackers and you know,
the first day it's not so bad.
You're like,
oh,
I can do this.
Like some crackers and a little bit of soup and then day two and day three and
you're like,
oh my God,
I'm dying.
Right.
But it's not nearly as bad as water only.
Um,
but the,
the,
the idea is that you eat just enough food to still get into this fasted state.
So all of your inflammation markers,
all of the things that,
the different markers that are looking at in your blood,
they look just like you're,
you're doing a water only fast but with a minimal amount of food.
So you have a little bit of,
not as much hunger and a little bit more energy.
And so the compliance is much higher.
Were you tracking when you do these FMDs,
have you tracked your ketone levels at all?
Do you get into ketosis or does the small amount of carbohydrate and so on that
you're consuming keep you out of Ketosis?
I get a mild,
I would say I get around 0.5 or so millimolars so it's like a very my own the
edge,
right,
which is kind of brutal cause the,
you're kind of in the Keto flu symptom area and so you're not fully into
ketosis.
Well this is really interesting because um,
so uh,
Tia Peter Attia who you've got on the show a few times,
he's my doctor and I know you work with them as well and we've kind of like
played around with this,
this protocol in that um,
uh,
Tia has put together an FMD diet that is a lot more ketogenic friendly,
so a lot heavier on the fats and a lot less on the refined carbohydrates.
So for example,
when you're doing long goes version of this diet and he actually has a nonprofit
called prolonged,
so you'd actually just ordered this kit.
So I get a kid in the mail that has all the prepackaged food.
If you're watching the video version of this,
this is what it looks like here as happened to have one of this is like day five
or day five.
What do they do?
What does the nonprofit do with the money that they get?
Because it looks very research,
it goes back into research.
That's right.
And,
and Longo doesn't receive any of the,
in any of the money at all.
He doesn't take a salary.
Um,
and so,
you know,
this is meant for people that want to create a little autophagy,
a little cell death,
um,
uh,
generate new stem cells,
which he has proven.
I'm actually happens via this five day method.
And so the thing that hooked me though is I have had and elevated cholesterol.
Uh,
I'm on my whole father's side of the family and that's turned into heart disease
with my dad and him passing away from a heart attack.
My grandpa passed away from a heart attack.
My Grandma on my dad's side passed away from a heart attack.
So like it's,
it's running deep.
Uh,
and it's a little bit scary,
you know,
now that I'm 40,
I've got,
um,
these,
uh,
pretty bad numbers,
so,
so much so that,
uh,
a tia has put me on Crestor,
which is,
um,
you know,
knocking back the bad cholesterol,
um,
with the Staten.
But obviously I'd prefer not to be on a statin.
Anyway,
long story short,
um,
I decided to,
because of his book,
the longevity diet,
I was reading through it and he said that he was seeing people that did the five
day fast,
they were improving their cholesterol numbers,
um,
and they were getting more good cholesterol and less bad cholesterol.
So I was like,
oh,
that sounds interesting.
I might as well give this a shot.
But to give it a proper shot you're supposed to do.
And I and I talked too long about this,
but three back to back,
five day fasts of the over three months and then once a quarter.
Okay.
So you do,
there's like a loading phase of fast.
That's right.
You do whatever the first week of each month for three months and the king of
fascinating.
Right.
And then you do maintenance once a quarter thereafter.
That's right.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I did the first five day fast three months ago.
Um,
had my blood work drawn,
drawn pre and post,
um,
you know,
small,
minor improvements,
second fast,
same thing.
And then by the third we actually saw a dramatic drop on a few different fronts
cholesterol wise and a tia was like when he called me up my uh,
cause we do these like little,
you know,
calls to go over my blood work and he was like,
Kevin,
you're going to,
you're going to live to 90 if you keep this up.
This is amazing.
So he was shocked and he was blown away.
And so,
um,
we're pretty happy with the results.
We'll see how long they stick.
Um,
and this is no dietary changes.
This is just,
I mean granted there's a dietary change during those five days,
but no,
like long term,
I'm still kind of sticking to the same diet that I've always been been sticking
to.
I liked it.
He was so specific with 90,
that's lower than I would've expected.
So it must be all the way with it.
It must be all the math that you're doing that's going to kill you.
Yeah.
I mean I still do a dose of Methadone every now and then,
but no,
actually speak at Meth,
dude.
I just did some lt and even for the first time today.
Yeah.
Have you tried this with coffee?
I,
it is very interesting stuff to be sure.
My God,
dude,
I had never tried it before.
I took a pill of it.
I took a 200 milligrams this morning and I was out with with a a mutual friend,
Tony Conrad.
We met for coffee and I gave him the pill too and we were like cracked out for
like three hours,
man.
Yeah,
so this observing of the bio hacking is a mutual arrangement that Kevin and I
have.
It's not just him watching be squirting fluid out of my elbow.
I also observe things that you do now on the f on the FMD though,
just to return to that for a second,
you mentioned in passing that a tia had looked at the possibility of doing a
lower carbohydrate,
higher fat yeah.
Protocol for that.
Yeah.
I'm sure he'd,
he'd give you the pdf if you,
if you asked for it for the podcast notes.
Have you tried it?
I did,
yeah.
I did that for the second one and it was,
I liked it.
Um,
actually I just happened to buy a three pack of the prolonged kids.
I wanted to go through them and use them because they're not cheap.
And so I just use that for the last one.
But I like it.
Tias and that it's a little bit more work obviously because you're preparing
your own food.
But it's largely like his is different in that with ProLon you get these little
tiny snacks throughout the entire day with his,
it's one meal a day and it's a,
it's just a salad.
It's like a Greens and like,
you know,
three tablespoons or four tablespoons of olive oil and like six,
all of us.
And you know,
like some sunflower seeds.
Like it's not,
it's not a whole lot,
but it certainly is,
is,
um,
gives you,
it's not as refined.
And so you,
uh,
I saw my ketone levels go up on his versus,
and I,
I think I had certainly more energy on his versus the prolonged.
Got It.
Well,
I'll Ping Peter about that.
It makes sense that you would on multiple levels that you would have higher
ketone levels.
And for people who are wondering how one would measure ketone levels,
uh,
think you and I still use the same device,
which is the precision xtra x t r a by Abbott labs,
which does a sufficient job in measuring something called Bhb Beta
hydroxybutyrate in the blood for,
uh,
for a number of different reasons.
This is a much more precise and accurate,
well,
let's just call it precise,
but consistently precise.
Maybe it's accurate,
maybe it isn't a method of measuring ketones or whether the degree to which
you're in Ketosis then peasticks because as your body becomes,
or if you're already very efficient at using ketone bodies,
uh,
you could show a false negative where you pee on this,
on the stick.
It tells you you're not in Ketosis when in fact you are so the blood,
the blood is just more accurate.
Uh,
well I'm glad you're going to live to 90.
That makes me happy.
Yeah,
I mean it was a,
it was a pretty cool experiment and certainly for someone that has heart disease
running in their family,
um,
I'm going to keep it up.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do another blood draw here next week to see where my levels are at and
then I'm trying to do this quarterly that's in,
hopefully if we can get it down to,
um,
where I won't be using Stanton's any longer,
that'd be great.
The last time we did a random show,
it was a very,
very long ago,
I believe
it was,
at least before you had a little monkey in your house.
And,
uh,
a reason,
many reasons of course to stick around,
but now a very compelling new reason.
So what is it w how would you describe,
since certainly I have no kids that I'm aware of at this point that's a good
claim or they're just,
you know,
that I,
I don't have kids asterisks that I know of.
Uh,
what have been the biggest changes that you've felt or observed in yourself or
otherwise?
How you view the world or anything like that?
And now that you have a kid and what is your kid's name?
I know you've Zelda.
She's four months old and she's named after the video game because,
um,
one of the first things that my wife and I bonded on a very early on in our
relationship was our love for the game.
Zelda.
And actually the new Zelda game allows you to track your hours played.
They actually shows it in like the little settings menu.
And so Daria has,
um,
like over 200 hours play to the latest Zelda.
So she's,
she's hardcore.
She played it a lot during your pregnancy is a true believer end.
When we were in Japan a long time ago,
uh,
Daria was using some type of emulator,
I don't know what it,
what device it was on exactly what she was playing Zelda on all of the trains
when we were sitting down and chilling.
That's original.
Yeah.
Josh Cook was too.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's,
it's fun to play the original ones with those old school emulators.
Um,
but yeah,
so in,
in terms of her,
I mean it's,
it's hard for,
I think a guy in that when you first have your first child,
it's,
it's like,
um,
there's not a whole lot to do.
There's just like a lot of crying.
And so it's,
you know,
I tried to help out where I can,
but it's really like,
you know,
on the hip of mom,
she was for the first several weeks and just,
there's a lot of getting used to new things and then now it's just,
it's just amazing to have you walk into a room and she lights up when she sees
me for the first time,
she smiles and giggles and,
you know,
it kind of changes the way that I want to approach life in terms of,
um,
what things are important and trying to make more time to be a good father.
And so,
uh,
for someone like myself and that has so many varying interests in,
in certainly can get sucked into new things pretty easily.
I've been trying to be a little bit more thoughtful about where,
where,
and when I spend my energy.
Um,
so that I can kind of dial back,
you know,
so I've spent a good portion of this year trying to live a little bit more
minimalist lifestyle.
What are some of the steps that you've taken to do that?
Well,
um,
one of the things I feel like you and I have had this conversation every year
since we first met,
but now you actually have a,
a gigantic incentive to follow through.
It's funny,
every time I get together it's just like,
aw man,
I've got too many investments.
I'm doing this.
There's many things going on.
And I got into my time here and we're always like,
come more or less complaining to each other of just like,
just taking on too many things.
Um,
even it's so ridiculous.
uh,
so I just been trying to
implement a few rules.
So one of the things I did start in January 1st was to throw away or donate
something every single day.
And so I have forced myself to go in.
And so for example,
um,
a few days ago I went in and I just like picked out all the clothes that I
haven't touched in a year and I took them down the street.
Like I had a half a block away is a donation place and I donated anything that I
hadn't worn in a year.
And it really thins out your closet and I've been just announced it.
Was that easy for you to do or do have an absolutely it was,
there was no resistance.
You are like,
but that's the sweater that my Auntie Jaynie gave me and no,
I mean who's that lady you had in your podcast that wrote that book on repleting
called Marie Kondo.
Yes.
Will,
this isn't technically muddy on those,
how they would say in Japanese,
but Marie Kondo.
Marie Kondo,
yeah.
She's awesome.
So I listened to her audio book and one of the things that she says in her audio
book is that the way that you can depart with something is to realize that it is
already taught you it's lesson.
And that lesson may be that it wasn't for you.
Right.
So like if you have it hanging in your closet and you look at and you're like,
oh,
but I have some day,
I might know the lesson is that it spent its time with you.
It wasn't for you and it should go to a good home or it can be appreciated by
someone else.
And so my lesson is not to buy it again.
And,
and,
and so I took that and I've applied that to thinning out pretty much everything
in my life.
And so every single day,
and I think that a lot of people,
there's like this analysis paralysis thing where you think about cleaning out
the garage.
Are you thinking about doing this massive overhaul in your life?
And you're like,
oh,
you know,
I just,
the weekend I got to do this.
And there's always something that jumps in front of it in terms of priorities.
For me,
it's like I find that if I just say,
okay,
one thing a day,
like at the end of the year I'm going to,
I may not be to my goal,
but after five years I certainly will.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's not like I have that much stuff,
but just really saying,
do I need this in my life and is it bringing joy to my life I think is such a
good forcing function to like get rid of a lot of stuff and everything that you
get rid of is actually less of a mental load on you.
There was this,
uh,
old tea master that I'm at one time and Tim and I have done some crazy travels
all throughout China,
um,
in,
in t lands,
but there was this,
there was this one guy I met the stories we could tell.
Yes,
seriously.
We've done some crazy stuff in the middle of the Yunan province,
nothing sexual.
Um,
that was our friend.
We gotta do something.
So a long story short,
um,
the,
the one thing that,
um,
this,
this tea master showed me is he pulled out of his pocket one key and he showed
me the one kid.
He goes,
Kevin,
do you know what this is?
And I,
as I get is,
it's a key,
you know,
and he's like,
yeah,
it's,
it's the key to my house.
Like it,
this is,
this is my one key.
He's like,
I've worked my entire life to have one key because we can all have multiple
keys.
You know,
you meaning like the things that you purchase,
whether you have a key to your boat or your spare garage or another,
you know,
a,
a motorcycle or whatever it may be.
There's things in your life that you accumulate and the least amount of burden
and the most happiness you can get is like having less stuff to worry about.
And so the,
I find that to be really true.
And so that's what I've been trying to focus on is,
is just having less and being happy with,
uh,
a very handful of high quality things.
I also want to mention that
it's possible to read a book like Marie Condo's book,
which I can never remember the title of,
cause I want to say it's like the magic art of Japanese tidying up.
Then it's like,
no,
it's something close.
It's like the art of the joy of magic cleaning up.
I can never remember the exact phrasing.
I don't know why,
but in any case,
that coal following with her book leads some readers to think it's an all or
nothing,
take it or leave it approach.
So you on the other hand have philosophically found bits and pieces of that book
that are very useful to you,
but her teacher tactically actually doing the opposite of what she recommends,
but it works for you.
So she recommends doing this like once in a lifetime tidying Superbowl basically
where you black out two or three days of your life and that's what you do.
And then the rest is maintenance.
It's kind of like the fast,
the fast mimicking diet of Japanese tiding,
right?
You have this loading phase.
And I've had this book,
I actually am looking at it on my bookshelf right now for like two years and I'm
just like,
man,
I'm going to do it.
And then I'm like two to three days,
I look at my calendar,
I'm like,
no,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm just not going to do it.
So I like the idea tactically of one at a time.
Uh,
one per day.
And also,
uh,
what's,
what's helped me because I do,
I have actually been,
since I moved to Austin not too long ago,
it's been a great opportunity after boxing everything up,
it's like,
okay,
do I really want to unbox all this stuff or do I just want to donate a lot of
this?
Because it might be from a one to 10 scale of value,
a two to me or maybe a one,
maybe a three,
but I could donate this very easily to goodwill or somewhere else to say a high
school gym that needs equipment,
which is something I've done in the past and it's an immediate eight,
nine or 10.
It's just a better,
it's,
it's an,
it's a,
it's a nice karmic chess move to donate and you said to think of not what you're
losing,
but also what you're giving to someone else in that respect.
Uh,
which I find really helpful.
So you're giving away one item per day.
The other thing too,
I will tell you along those lines is that if there is a purchase that I want to
make,
um,
that is not just what I would consider to be a,
you know,
a necessity like toilet paper or whatever it may be.
Um,
and it's something that is,
is,
is luxury or not luxury,
but in the sense of like,
you know,
it's going to cost you over a hundred dollars and I don't necessarily need it,
but I kind of want to try it.
Um,
you can,
what I do is I save for later on Amazon's,
you can add and say save for later and you know,
set a reminder in your calender app for a week or two weeks later.
And almost 90% of the time I ended up not buying that thing.
I still have one thing in there actually from you.
It's um,
uh,
that not NAC knock supplement.
Yeah.
Should I buy that?
And it's not decided yet.
Well,
NEC,
uh,
so this is,
I should say with all of this stuff that we're discussing because it bears
repeating,
we are not doctors,
we don't play them on the Internet.
So everybody,
everybody should assume that at least 50% of what we're saying is complete
fucking nonsense and we're just not sure which 50% it is.
So work with a qualified professional before you start taking course stopping
any type of medication or supplement.
The NBC
came to me initially because I was,
I was looking at at it as a means to accelerate recovery between workouts and
uh,
my understanding,
I might be getting this wrong,
but is that it is a precursor to glutathione,
which some people think of as this
master antioxidant or upstream antioxidant that has a host of beneficial
effects.
And what I noticed in taking the NAC is that I was over the period of a week to
10 days,
perhaps seven,
eight days into it that I was,
I was more even keeled than tip than,
than was typical.
I felt very like the week had been very smooth and I hadn't changed anything
else that I could identify.
I had been either meditating or not meditating for a series of weeks.
There were a lot of constants and when I went on to pub med and began to look at
an Acetyl cystine and search for other terms like depression or bipolar and so
on,
there were a number of search results that popped up that seemed to indicate to
me that there was some promise in using NAC to mitigate the amplitude of the ups
and downs that could be associated with say bipolar and that that's the primary
reason that for for periods of time and I cycle off of all of these things,
I become very fascinated by NAC,
which quite nicely does have potentially recovery benefits from an athletic
standpoint.
Although most of my athletic prowess has been focused on eating oatmeal cookies
recently.
So I can't really claim that I'm doing a lot of,
uh,
killer workouts.
I got rhabdo from eating oatmeal cookies for you crossfitters out there.
That's for you.
But,
uh,
the other would be something you and I are both familiar with.
It's with a,
which is a low dose lithium Orotate,
very,
very low dose lithium Orotate five milligrams,
which you can find on Amazon and elsewhere.
And uh,
there's a great New York Times article which people can find very easily that is
titled a long the lines of maybe we all just need a little bit of lithium and it
talks about the inverse correlation of groundwater concentrations of lithium
with,
I want to say at least reported suicide,
homicide,
manic depression,
uh,
and so on.
So those two for me function in tandem or at least appeal to me for very similar
reasons.
So the NAC should you use it or not,
I think is a question of whether you feel you need it.
And for me at least currently,
uh,
I get asked all the time like,
what are your top 10 supplements that you're using right now?
Because people have this impression after reading the four hour body and so on
that I'm just like,
I walk around with a drip,
ivy bag in my arm and have a thousand pills.
I'm taking the four times a day.
I've certainly seen you in that scene that no,
you have seen me in that mode,
but my mode right now is to really ensure that I am using supplements as
supplements and that I'm not using them to absolve me of the responsibility to
eat proper food,
for instance.
And it's like,
look,
if you're drinking a lot and you're like compulsively watching porn and not
exercising and like mainlining pixie sticks for your diet and you're like,
wow,
I'm depressed,
maybe I should take 15 different supplements.
It's like,
no,
you need to fucking fix the rest of your life.
Right,
right,
right.
And then see what your baseline is because you're creating so much static and
noise and garbage inputs that you don't even know what your baseline is and
it's,
it's so disguised with sort of the,
the trauma and confusion of your inputs that you need to do.
You track your baseline,
like do you log what you,
what you consume and what you take.
I log,
you know,
my baseline.
Is this going to sound so primitive?
And it is,
but my baseline is really how do I feel when I wake up,
you know,
do I,
do I want to stay in bed because I don't want to face the day?
Am I anxious or those my first thoughts coming out of bed assuming that I'm not
checking my phone.
Right.
Because,
um,
it,
it's really my starting state out of the gate of wake,
sleep to wakefulness and then at night,
how much trouble do I have sleeping,
if any?
Or do I fall asleep easily?
How deep is my sleep?
And so for deepness of sleep,
you could certainly use something like an aura ring or an accelorometer.
I mean,
there are different means by which you could try to assess the quality of your
sleep.
But from me
really looking at how consistently I feel good waking up and how long it takes
me to get up to say first or second gear because it does,
it,
it historically has taken me a long time to go from park to like second or third
gear.
Some people wake up and you might be one of these people and they're like,
fuck it world.
Here I am ready to party.
That's not me.
It's like I have a real slow build and
in between you and that I am definitely not ready to party the second I wake up,
get him after coffee.
I have a cup of coffee,
I'm ready party.
So I feel that way.
If for instance,
I'm in ketosis passed about two millimeters.
Hmm.
I need less sleep.
So let's call it six versus eight hours.
And when I wake up,
I'm awake versus feeling groggy for an hour or two hour and a half,
uh,
which can be remedied somewhat by the psychological advantage of exercising in
the morning,
which is one thing I've been scheduling to do more of.
Uh,
Jocko Willink,
a retired navy seal commander and all around intense,
intense,
accomplished guy.
Uh,
people can find him.
Tim.
Dot.
Blog slash Jocko first ever public interview.
Uh,
so I'm thrilled to have unleashed the giant white gorilla on the Internet.
And,
uh,
baseline though to return to your question is really something I try to keep as
simple as possible.
Do I,
and have I measured all those other things?
Yes.
But I think that whether it's with your body or with a business
yeah.
Or any number of other things,
it's really easy to become addicted to measuring things that don't matter very
much.
Uh,
or,
uh,
we're still measuring things that will distract you from the things that do
matter.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I've,
I've tried to kind of pair it down to the,
just the stuff I really care about.
I just sent you a link in our video chat,
um,
to my dashboard for the things I measure every day.
Cool.
Um,
so for me,
you know,
I'm really concerned about my glucose levels because they are a tiny bit hell of
it elevated.
So I do Waking Glucose,
bedtime,
glucose.
I do,
whether I meditated that day or not,
I do.
How many hours I fasted the night prior.
I do,
how many drinks I've had and then I do what type of workout,
whether I had tea or coffee that day and then my food,
but food,
not in terms of kind of a a bike by the calorie,
you know,
super anal kind of breakdown,
but really just typing out what I ate for that day as a way to hold myself
accountable and just like look over the last few days at a glance and see if
I've been behaving or not.
So I find that just the act of writing it down makes me behave a little bit
better.
It does.
Okay.
That was going to be my question is how does that actually impact your behavior?
I,
you know,
this is a fascinating question.
I,
I've,
I didn't experiment here about,
um,
three weeks ago with a group of five and I asked them all,
I created this spreadsheet that we all logged into every single day.
And what you do is you record the number of drinks you had the night before.
And I was thinking about turning this into an APP,
although I'm not going to do it.
But I was interested in trying to create social pressure to drink less,
not to drink more,
but to drink less.
And the thing that I found that was really interesting is that if you drink over
two drinks in a night,
people have some shame and reporting that.
And so they will misreport.
So you know,
if you went out and you had like four or five drinks,
it's like,
ah,
I don't want to be the guy that had the one that's on the spreadsheet.
Right,
exactly.
So I changed it then.
So the spreadsheet would only say two plus.
And so that's the Max you could go.
And then people were a lot more like open to being like,
yeah,
I had two plus last night.
You know,
there were a lot more at ease.
Right.
But it still created a little bit of social pressure and personal pressure.
If you looked at your list and you're like,
Ooh,
there's been four nights of two plus there,
I should probably do a night without drinking.
Right.
So my idea was to create an app that would allow you just to say up to two plus
and see all of your friends in the same arena and then kind of hopefully
encourage you to be able to drink socially but not take it too far.
Yeah,
the springs up all sorts of really fascinating and frustrating methodological
questions in terms of designing this type of reporting.
Right.
Because I was thinking to myself as you were saying this,
well,
if you had a larger group,
say a group of 200 people,
you would have one would expect you would have more people in that group
reporting drinking two,
three,
four drinks on any given night.
So the shame factor would be decreased.
But if you decrease the shame factor,
that also decrease the incentive to actually behave.
Right?
Because you can blend into this right perceived acceptability of being like,
well,
there are the 10 other people out of 200 about four drinks last night.
That's totally fine.
We're well,
the question is like how well do you know the people want,
so how tight are they are?
And you're like kind of social connections in your,
your peer group.
And then also I think that there is,
when I like Brennan Mulligan I'll call him out cause he's a friend of ours,
he works at Google.
He like never drinks like he is like one drink,
one drink,
you know like wondering every four days or whatever.
And seeing him hit those streaks of like zero drinks,
zero drinks,
that was also a pretty powerful thing.
And I'm saying I need to be more like Brendan,
I need to dial it back.
So it goes both ways.
Yeah,
that's true.
I suppose if you're seeing friends of yours doing well,
doing well,
who have demanding jobs,
demanding relationships,
you can't use that as your excuse when you have the data right in front of you
showing that they're actually behaving.
So you,
you uh,
you historically have been a nontrivial drinker,
let's call it a a like a minor league,
all star of,
of boost consumption.
I used to drink a lot more to be honest,
my spreadsheet here.
So what has helped you most to decrease the amount that you drink?
Well I think there is fear.
Um,
you know,
I've seen a bunch of studies.
There was one that was just published here a couple of weeks ago.
There's the said the number one.
Um,
I the largest study ever around a dementia and alcohol abuse.
And um,
they're very closely linked,
which is really frightening.
Um,
and I think just,
you know,
wanting to live longer for my daughter's been another one back to the point that
you had earlier about what has changed.
Um,
and just getting older,
you know,
hangovers get,
it happened at two and a half drinks these days.
It's so,
it's like why,
why roll the dice?
And so for me it's,
um,
it,
it's finding,
uh,
to,
to get to your question around what have I done differently.
There's a couple things.
Um,
one I've like kind of set aside time to learn at night,
which I think is really important and you really can't drink and learn at the
same time.
So,
um,
on a order,
remember what you attempt to learn.
Right.
Exactly.
And the second thing that has been huge for me though has been the sauna.
The sauna has been massive because it is like four drinks or three drinks just
by going and doing a 30 minute high intense heat sauna session.
Um,
and you come home and you sleep like a baby and you know,
if you don't have a sauna,
that can also be substituted with a really hot bath.
And just finding ways to,
it's like that.
It's always been about,
I'm with my wife,
I'm sitting down and we're going to crack open a bottle of wine and I'll have a
couple of glasses of wine.
It's never been like,
Hey,
let's go party.
Those days are long gone,
like,
you know,
a decade plus gone.
Um,
I've,
no decade,
decade plus,
and if we're out traveling together,
Tim,
I'm going to,
we're going to have fun.
Right.
Okay.
So the only thing you and I hang,
it's like when we're traveling together,
so you can't,
like,
you can't put that on me.
That's true.
All right.
Fair enough.
We're in different cities now.
I will say for those people who were like,
wait,
they can see each other.
Uh,
we are doing a very intimate,
uh,
video chat on Skype that you,
you will be able to see on my youtube channel,
just youtube.com forward slash timferriss two r's,
two s's.
And Kevin is dressed for success.
I will note he is at a partner meeting this morning,
so we dress up a little bit.
I appreciate it.
So,
uh,
so I gave you that look traveling's a bit of an exception.
Now,
how do you prevent yourself?
You like you have traveled a lot in some cases historically now that may change
with your daughter,
but how do you prevent that from becoming the excuse to drink that happens
frequently?
Does that make sense?
Because this happens in all sorts of capacities,
right?
Where people will say,
oh,
you're traveling.
You should eat pizza every night.
Right?
I hear that.
And I'm like,
if I,
if I followed that rule,
I'll be Jabba the Hutt because I,
I,
I ended up traveling so much.
If I allowed myself that out,
it would become a real problem.
Yeah,
yeah.
Traveling is,
is difficult and especially when it's in kind of a,
a social setting,
you know,
if you combine traveling with social,
like,
you know,
I'll be going to,
um,
to,
to Ted in a couple of weeks and I know that there's just going to be a lot of
parties and a lot of events and a lot of drinking.
So,
um,
I think that's one of the things that I need to work on is that I have a hard
time dealing with like large groups of people that I don't know.
And as a social lubricant,
alcohol is amazing,
right?
So it's like what else can we do?
And,
and I think that that someone was telling me this,
that,
um,
you know,
you never really strengthen that muscle.
Like if you're leaning on the crutch of alcohol,
so you're never going to become more comfortable with new humans and new
interactions and new ways of kind of breaking the ice if you always just go to
the booze,
right?
So I think of it as like,
okay,
this is my workout I'm going into.
And the other thing I do is I,
so I've got a couple of little hacks.
One is to show up a little bit late,
so you then you skip a drink,
right?
And it's funny how if you skip a drink or two and you get there and people are
already a little hammered.
How unattractive and unappealing drinking them becomes because you look at it
and it was like,
hey,
it's good to see,
you know,
and it's like a little bit sloppy and it's,
and you look at that and you're like,
okay,
they're relaxed.
They're not going to like,
you know,
remember what I said anyway,
that Hammer.
But you know what I mean?
They're,
they're in a relaxed state,
so I can be a little bit more jokey and be myself and not have to worry about
being hammered.
And so I think that that's a big piece of it.
Um,
you know,
when I'm at home,
you're going to laugh at this.
But on Amazon I went in,
I bought these,
um,
speaking,
buying more things and probably I'm going to throw away in a year.
Um,
I bought these measuring cups that measure out exactly one glass of wine.
And so what I do there is like,
you know,
a,
a bottle of wine we all know is like kind of like a half bottle of wine.
It's like kind of two and a half maybe,
you know,
it's,
it's up there and it's very easy.
Like,
like Daria,
we'll just like have a little bit less than me and I'll say,
okay,
well I'll just wait until he gets halfway and then I'll stop,
you know,
just try and,
but you're actually drinking more than you think.
So,
yeah.
Plus with a wine glass,
I mean if you have a large wine glass you can drink like a third of a bottle or
supposed to have to know very easily.
Right,
exactly.
So what I do now is I bought this measuring,
um,
glass off of Amazon.
I feel that perfectly poured in,
get my second glass,
Phillip perfectly import in.
And so that's all of my alcohol for the night.
It stops me at two drinks and I,
I really take my time with it.
Then,
you know,
I have dinner,
I slowly sit,
but I look at it,
you know,
I go sit down,
might watch a little John Oliver or something and then just like continue to sip
on it.
And so that's my,
my way of locking.
And I know no more past that.
It's prevents any hangovers.
You know,
my doctor says it's pretty good for you to have a glass or two a night.
So,
um,
and then also do,
don't laugh.
It is good for you.
Okay,
I'll go with this
now.
But then it's also just taking nights off all together.
I think that's the other big piece of it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Good for you man.
I love it.
Now you mentioned one other thing,
well actually a couple of other points cause I've been also cutting back on
alcohol quite a bit.
I still enjoy alcohol.
Not going to lie.
Like I do have booze on occasion.
I love you're drunk.
Like oh,
the drunk dials.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
those are,
those are fun.
So for those who don't know,
occasionally I do these drunk dial up so it's where I will,
it's the laziest podcast format thought up I think to date perhaps,
which is I have listeners fill out a Google form with their contact info and I
set a time like a two hour window where I will call people via Skype and drink,
start drinking at call one and drink all the way through to say call 10 and get
progressively more inebriated as I answer questions so that that is fun.
I did one about a week ago,
it was a good time and then I thought,
you know I should do another episode today.
And I was like,
I just don't want to do two nights of sipping Tequila on Skype and a few things
that have also helped me.
Number one is,
and this is not an excuse everyone's going to be comfortable using,
but if I go to a party and they're like,
hey man,
you're not drinking it,
what the fuck?
Like [inaudible] I'll be like,
yeah,
I'm on a bunch of weird drugs.
Like,
I just actually,
I'm not really interested post to take out,
I'm not supposed to drink alcohol right now,
which that stops the conversation right there.
That's brilliant.
Yeah.
Well it stops the push.
Right.
And then it also starts another conversation,
which is,
well,
what kind of weird shit are you on?
And if you,
at any given point,
I think it's fair to say that I could answer in the affirmative to,
are you on any weird shit?
Like I'm almost always doing something odd.
Uh,
I might not be a lot of stuff,
but I'm probably trying something new and uh,
that stops people cold if they're like,
oh wow.
I mean it could be Tylenol,
like if you're taking Acetaminophen in any capacity,
people may not realize this,
but some absurd percentage of emergency room visits and,
uh,
liver failures are associated with high dose Acetaminophen,
which is not that much.
It's something like two or three times the label allowable amount over 24 hours.
It's really a potent and potentially dangerous drug.
Uh,
so that's one is like,
Hey,
I'm actually on this.
I mean on a,
B and C or I'm on a bunch of weird stuff at the moment and I'm just not supposed
to drink a works really well in second.
This is actually advice that Richard Branson gave on this podcast is having club
soda with a dash of cranberry juice or something like that.
And just using that as your
default go to.
And uh,
you know,
one thing that I do,
which is going to sound really odd and it is odd,
but I have a superstition about say cheersing
right.
Clinking glasses when I don't have any alcohol in my glass.
So interesting.
Just your towel.
This is,
this is something,
well,
it's kind of a tell,
but what I'll do is I will sometimes also go up to the bar and I'll say,
just give me a tiny splash,
like,
uh,
like the equivalent amount that would be in a thimble or something like that.
And then I'll,
then I'll cut myself off at that.
And that's the amount that I allow myself.
That's another approach that I take to cut back on,
on the,
on the booze.
You mentioned though that you've been trying to learn at night and that the
booze is not conducive to learning at night.
What are you trying to learn at night?
What types of things and what's the format?
You reading a hundred a hundred pages a night or what does it honestly,
have you heard of this Coursera course called learning how to learn?
I have not.
Who Teaches?
Oh,
so it's done by a couple professors and I'm actually in the middle of that right
now.
Um,
it was another kind of biohacker recommended it to me.
Yeah.
Apparently it's the number one watched course on Coursera right now.
And it's just been fascinating how they dig into the science of learning and
like how,
um,
you go in this kind of like focused or defused mode and how to really go in and
concentrate on something and when the optimal time is to learn and it's all the
science around learning.
What is that?
Oh,
sorry to interrupt.
Go ahead.
And I'm just getting,
I'm just getting started with it.
So that's,
that's what I've been diving into and kind of spending my nights watching those
videos.
Um,
but it talks about the importance of actually getting away from your material.
So like getting really focused and setting a timer for 25 minutes,
maximum going really in depth on the,
the,
the course material and then backing away and kind of going into this more
relaxed mode.
Um,
they're talking about how,
uh,
was it,
um,
Benjamin Franklin and Kimra,
who was that used to hold a pair of keys in their hand and then Kinda in
Salvador Dali to this as well actually hold a pair of keys in your hand.
You kind of just go into this relaxed state thinking about,
um,
what you want to learn and to where you almost fall asleep and when you drop the
keys out of your hand and it wakes you up,
that's when you kind of go back and then you realize you were successful.
Like getting that,
that relaxed and you'll retain and become more creative.
And I don't know,
it's just fascinating stuff.
And so I'm just getting started with the course.
It's free.
Very cool.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the intervals and the duration of intervals for learning along with break
periods is,
is something that I've experimented a lot with as it relates to language
learning because it's so measurable.
You can look at say your recall of foreign vocabulary,
assuming you're controlling for a few different variables,
right?
So,
uh,
adjectives are generally going to be harder than nouns for instance.
But if you're controlling for that,
you can look at what your retention is,
say 48 hours later for a hundred words you attempted to learn in one session
versus two sessions versus three sessions with different types of breaks.
And I did that when I was looking at a few different languages specifically were
2004,
2005.
Actually,
I've never shown you these notes.
I have text edit documents
with all of my notes on language learning for about a year,
year long period,
looking at all of this type of stuff.
And uh,
there were some very clear patterns such as focusing on the material right
before bed with no interruption.
So much like how it's recommended by many names.
Both you and I know that you meditate first thing in the morning before you
brush your teeth,
before you check your phone before anything else.
When you have this Tabula Rasa,
blank state of sorts,
uh,
focusing on material that you want to consolidate and memory and recall later,
right before bed,
uh,
at least in my experience,
dramatically improves recall.
And then this is actually very important,
not just doing that,
but when you wake up before doing anything else,
which for me would override meditation,
doing a recall exercise of some type.
I tend to use flashcards to determine which of stuck in which have not.
So those that have not,
since I'm looking at language,
I would usually,
I would give myself like a quarter of a second.
It couldn't be delayed because in speech you're not going to have the luxury of
sitting there pause for long periods of time.
It would go back into the rotation for review again throughout that day and
later that night.
Uh,
but that's,
that is proven and really,
really helpful.
How about exercise?
One of the things I mentioned in this course is this idea of doing
cardiovascular exercise.
I believe it's post learning something new.
And apparently this science was saying that it just sticks.
I'm that much more,
I don't have any numbers in front of me,
but it was,
it was something along.
Have you heard anything about that?
Uh,
so I,
I have in terms of a spacing or I'm sorry,
the,
the timing of exercise.
Uh,
I,
I have less clarity,
but there's an entire book called spark that talks about the,
uh,
among other things,
the role of exercise in education and learning and would point to things like
BDNF,
the release of brain drive neurotrophic factor,
which can be elicited through different types of exercise.
And you know,
part of me thinks that,
uh,
when one says,
because these are the easiest to study or very often the easiest to study
cardiovascular exercise,
uh,
this is where it comes down to try to become literate with reading scientific
studies or understanding how things typically work.
So as a couple of baselines,
scientific studies usually use volunteer populations known as students.
And those students have 45 minute class blocks or 60 minute class blocks.
So to keep those students busy,
people are very often disincentivized from using shorter duration,
say a high intensity training,
uh,
or or something like that.
Weightlifting for instance,
resistance training.
And if you want to as an experimenter,
designed something that requires as little monitoring as possible.
It's like,
all right,
stick them on a stationary bike,
right?
If you have people doing burpees or dead lifts,
like you actually need to hate burpees,
you need to pay attention,
right?
You need to pay attention if people are lifting weights and so on.
There are more safety concerns.
So I think that just to point out,
perhaps the obvious that weightlifting is actually one of the most
cardiovascular activities you could possibly engage in.
Uh,
but I won't digress into that.
You can look at a book called body by science,
uh,
for,
for all the details and why that is the case.
But it would make sense to me that exercise could certainly play a role in
increasing cognitive function.
But one of the questions that I ask myself all the time,
uh,
when,
and this is a good question for people to ask themselves when they see a
headline that makes a scientific claim is what else could explain this?
Like what else might explain this?
So if you're looking at cardiovascular exercise,
right after some type of cramming with material,
you could make the argument that perhaps it's not the exercise at all.
It's the fact that they're going into a semi mindless or meditative repetition,
a repetitive period where they're,
they're able to,
their subconscious somehow work on the material.
Right,
right.
Well,
that's exactly what this,
this course teaches is how to get into those periods.
Yeah.
100%.
So the,
uh,
I have certainly seem to observe that exercise in some capacity.
For me,
it's generally some type of resistance training does have a positive effect on,
on learning.
So yet,
another reason to get off your ass,
which is something I need to do more of.
I've,
I've digressed a fallen off the train a little bit,
Kevin Rose,
I'll be honest.
Uh,
but I shall get back on the train.
yeah.
So fortunately,
you know,
once you have a recipe that works,
you have the confidence that you can get back on that.
That's the good news,
right?
With say the fast mimicking diet,
not that you should use that for body composition,
but fast mimicking diet or intermittent fasting,
which a lot of people use your app euro for a or a slow carb diet plus a handful
of things like kettle bell swings.
I just know this is why I'm not stressed out about being off the rails.
I kind of make,
make fun of myself about it.
Uh,
because it's like,
look,
if if I just follow the prescription,
like follow the algorithm for three to four weeks,
there's no magic involved.
Yeah.
It will work and I will have less like muffin top to grab one.
I'm in the sauna,
which will be,
which will make me happy.
Muffin top of the sun is the word you that little layered as little.
Yeah.
Well you also have like the,
the glistening Cinnabon effect because you're sweating.
It's,
it's a really unattractive look.
It's not a good look.
One thing I did want to talk about it,
which I think would be fun to chat about because we both done it.
Um,
real quick is the,
uh,
is Tony Robbins.
Yeah,
yeah.
Let's talk about it for sure.
So you recently had,
I've done two different Tony robins events,
a UPW unleash the power within,
which was my first event and then more recently in December of this last year
date with destiny,
which is a longer event.
Oh,
you did?
That?
I didn't know you did.
They would designate.
Did I did.
So I've done two events and,
uh,
some people have had a bit of exposure to date with destiny through the,
I am not your guru documentary,
which,
uh,
was,
was coproduced in fact by someone who's been on this podcast.
Brian Koppelman really accomplished filmmaker.
But what was your experience like first Tony Robbins event?
Yeah,
I mean,
it was kind of crazy.
I,
I've,
um,
thanks to you,
uh,
I got hooked up with him and,
and went down and got a chance to meet him and hang out with them.
Um,
I,
you know,
I think that Tony is this,
this kind of,
um,
he's proven himself now that he's been doing this for so long and he's doing it
for 40 plus years.
But I think that in,
in the back of my mind,
I kind of remember when I was a little kid,
the kind of like audio tape version,
infomercial version of Tony,
you know,
so there's always this stigma in my mind that was like,
oh,
is he trying to sell me something?
What's going on here?
You know,
and I will also watch this documentary.
And I was like,
wow,
this guy's clearly brilliant ease.
It takes this stuff very seriously and he's truly breaking through to people and
helping people change their lives.
And so it was like,
Hey,
I want to be in the bay area.
You know,
you should come down.
And I was like,
okay,
that sounds awesome.
It took a buddy of mine,
um,
that,
uh,
it has a lot of anxiety and he shall go unnamed buddy.
He wanted to go and he was like,
Kevin,
let's do this.
And I was like,
okay,
let's do it.
Um,
so went down for the three day event and I thought it was great.
I got to tell you,
it's,
you walk into it and I was in an arena where there was,
you know,
12,000 people.
And so there is a lot of people there and everybody is coming there for a
different reason.
Right?
So I was sitting across from a guy that had lost his legs and was a previously a
drug addict and I think he had some infection,
his legs or something had to happen both amputated.
Um,
I was sitting next to someone that she was running her own social media business
and just wanted to like,
uh,
you know,
get better with our business and improve her finances.
And um,
she was getting through a relationship that she had just ended and you know,
so everyone had something to kind of come in and bring to the table.
Of course we all do.
If we're honest with ourselves,
everyone has the one that something that are trying to work on.
And so,
you know,
I went in there and day one was awesome.
I mean,
Tony got out there and he spoke for like,
uh,
I dunno,
12 hours.
We were there until nine complete mutant.
Yeah.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
I don't even know when he pees.
Yeah.
I have no idea when it uses the bathroom or drinks water.
Just,
yeah,
it's just a machine.
The guys.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
I walked over the coals,
I'm with him and he,
he was like bring out some fresh Kohl's for Kevin.
And of course they put like fresh that you,
he walk,
you actually walk over coals the end of the night.
You've done this right?
I have,
yeah.
Did he bring out fresh goals for you?
I can't recall if he brought up fresh goals for me.
I think that might've been the,
the VIP treatment that you received.
It was a lot of fun and I think that the biggest takeaway for me was really,
um,
a couple things.
Uh,
one was definitely this thing called the wheel of life.
Did you have to do that?
You feel like your wheel?
I'm sure I did.
I should also point out that for the attendees at these events,
and I have a little bit more to say about this,
but the exercises that really,
and they,
they,
there are a very tactical prescriptive exercises,
but that the exercises that change someone else's trajectory and give them
extremely concrete next steps that have an impact are very often completely
different exercises from those that affect the person right next to you.
It's really something to behold,
but tell us about the,
the wheel of life.
Yeah.
So the wheel of life was interesting in that basically he gives you these areas
of your life and your to rank them,
um,
from zero to 10 on how far along and how kind of just happy you are with those
that,
those areas.
So for example,
a physical body,
right?
So for me I was like,
I got to give myself a four in this arena can be doing a lot better.
And then there's emotions and meaning.
Another one is relationships and other one is time.
Another one is your career and your mission in life.
Um,
and then there's finances.
And then the last one,
um,
is how you contribute,
like how you give back,
how you celebrate and contribute.
And so you go from,
from kind of zero to 10 and you ranked these out and you'll see my wheel doesn't
actually look like a wheel.
It's like a kind of lopsided.
But that's by design.
That's by design.
By the time you,
you look at this,
it gives you a clear view of like,
okay,
I really need to step out how I contribute and give back.
And so that allowed me to go really deep in my own personal life and,
and say,
what does it mean to contribute and give back for me?
And like,
you know,
you and I have both done,
um,
things in,
in terms of like going out and,
uh,
you know,
charity water or the Tony Hawk Foundation and giving away money.
But like,
just supporting a cause and,
and writing a check.
I don't know how you feel about this,
but for me it doesn't really mean it mean that I'm giving back.
I don't really feel like I'm contributing.
Yes,
I'm giving like cash,
but I'm not actually taking part in that process.
I'm not actually really helping out like anyone can write a check.
Um,
so what does it mean for me to contribute?
And the thing and the realization that I came to,
and actually there's some really powerful moments in this,
this conference where they turn out the lights and they like make you revisit
like certain times in your childhood and all these things.
And you know,
I felt myself kind of tearing up because one of the things I realized that I was
not giving back and in contributing in a meaningful way.
And the thing that I came to him that I realized is that my mother was verbally
abused by my father for many,
many,
many years.
And um,
you know,
definitely abusive behavior.
I'm never physically harmed or,
but you know,
I would say that the mental harm was,
is,
is bad or if not worse than,
than some of the physical harm.
And,
and,
um,
I realized that I want to actually lean in and help out women that have been
abused and that are in currently in abusive relationships.
And so a goal of mine over the next couple of years is finding the best possible
way to contribute back to that.
Not just informs of another check,
but actually how I can get involved and what that means.
Helping them build their products and build a better website or mobile apps or
any way that I can enable and use my technology skills to help with their
business,
I think would be something that would mean a lot to me.
So that was,
that was a great experience to have and I wouldn't have that if it wasn't for
Tony and I and,
and that was just one of many things I got out of the weekend.
So I would say that,
you know,
he's,
he's a bad ass.
It was,
it was pretty awesome.
Yeah.
He's a real master of his craft.
And what I would say to folks who have a certain image of Tony is that when you
go to an event like this,
I think the right away to approach it is to be skeptical,
but not cynical and open to trying all of the exercises he suggests and that
they're going to be components that may not agree with you in the sense that
there's a lot of jumping around.
There's a lot of music,
there's a lot of noise,
for lack of a better word,
and a lot of those elements made me uncomfortable.
They're not things that I would seek out.
Oh my God,
I could not see you dancing and jumping around.
Right,
right.
It's just not my thing.
So,
but the filter that I used going into it,
or the lens through which I was looking at it was,
it was made easier because one of my,
one of my very close friends I've known since college,
who's had multiple company exits,
is extremely,
extremely accomplished and he goes to unleash the power within every year as a
reset.
He's been 11 times,
maybe 12 now.
He's been to date with destiny six times and this,
and this guy is not a seminar junkie.
He's not someone who avoids the work and goes to listen to a motivational speech
so that he can feel better on a sugar high for two days and not take any next
steps.
Like this is not that guy.
He is an operator.
So the fact that he had been so many times,
uh,
really led me to want to stick with the entire event and I'm not going to lie.
I had hard points and then I mentioned this to you and it may not be the
exercise that had a,
a large impact on you,
but the dickens process that I ended up along with Tony,
uh,
including in tools of titans,
one of my more recent books,
because it had such a big impact,
made the entire event and easy.
I tend to 100 x return for me,
that was the last day too.
That's right.
So just that 30 to 60 minute exercise led me to dramatically improve my
relationship with my father,
to take responsibility for certain things that I had been telling myself were
unchangeable,
to really buckle down and step into discomfort,
to make some meaningful changes.
And it ended the,
those are changes,
uh,
at least the power within.
I want to say I went to now it's gotta be three to five years ago.
Uh,
those changes,
the ripple effects of those changes that I made then are still very tangible now
and then date with destiny.
Very similar,
but to go into it expecting that if you step into it and accept some level of
discomfort and commit to trying everything,
this is just my view that at least 50%,
you're going to end up discarding probably 20%.
You're going to find really uncomfortable and you're going to dislike actively.
And then I tend to 25%,
you're gonna go,
Holy Shit.
I can't believe how powerful that just was.
And it's not a lot of hand wavy,
woowoo ambiguity.
These exercises are really,
really,
really specific.
So you don't have to accept Tony as your one and only savior.
You don't have to believe that he is flawless because he is not.
He's just like everyone else.
He's a imperfect creature trying to do the best with the gifts and talents he's
developed.
Uh,
but the guy knows his shit and he actually,
he actually really cares.
And as I've gotten to know him over the last few years,
more and more so I've become more impressed with him,
not less impressed.
Uh,
and I,
that is at least if one were thinking of let's say,
attending one of these events and I have no,
I've zero vested interest and sending anyone to these events other than they,
they've had a material impact on my life.
That's why I was,
I was happy to see that you're going to attend,
uh,
that they go in with an open mind expecting that much like if you read any type
of book,
you're not expecting every line to be a life changing piece of gold.
You're hoping that net net,
it's going to be worth the time that you invested.
Yeah.
Right.
That's been my takeaway that it's absolutely been worth the time invested.
Yeah,
100% agree.
And I think that,
I'm like you going into this was a certainly a really uncomfortable thing for me
in terms of when they first start the music and people come out on stage and
they started dancing and like you can tell the people that have been there
before because they immediately like jump out of their seeds and like start like
kind of rocking out and throwing their hands in the air.
And I'm thinking to myself,
I hate dancing,
hate dancing.
I've never liked dancing with anyone,
my wife or anyone.
I always feel so awkward when I'm doing it.
You know,
like I'm like a geek that likes to sit in front of my computer at night.
And so it's like,
did I though it's something that another friend had told me that had gone and
said,
Hey Kevin,
like you just have to go with it.
Like if you want to get anything out of it,
you have to realize that he's doing this by designed to put you into a certain
state.
Right.
He wants to get to get you in the,
into an optimal state.
And the optimal that can mean like,
like wanting,
one example of,
of one thing that we did is we took something that was very serious to us,
like something like a limiting belief that you had held so seriously.
And you say it out loud in a very joking and like laughing way and everybody,
like 12,000 people are all doing this at the same time and you're like laughing
and saying it and it's kind of like breaking it down in your,
in your mind and letting you know that you don't have to take it so seriously
and you can joke about it and have fun with it because it's been forever since,
since,
um,
you know,
you've probably ever done that in your life.
Like you've the,
when was the last time you were to able to take something that you held so
seriously and so guarded and,
and have a good time with it.
And so he knows how to set up these little traps for you,
that,
that trick you into reframing things in your mind.
And it really does change your longterm perspective on things.
And Yeah,
I,
I'm doing,
I'm a fan.
I would definitely go back again.
I did the three day event,
the unleash the power within the same one as you.
Um,
but yeah,
I had had fun with it,
so,
so thanks for helping out with that.
Yeah,
man.
My pleasure.
I,
I would suggest also that,
uh,
that's,
that's Molly saying hello in the background for those people who can hear my dog
barking.
But that
is as a,
as a point of social proof.
And of course Tony is fully aware of,
of the sort of gravitas would bring,
but there are people,
for instance,
Mark Benioff of salesforce,
which I think has more than 10 billion in annual revenue.
Now,
uh,
who will point blank say that salesforce would probably not exist were it not
for Tony Robbins and still attends some of these events.
Uh,
he was right behind me at date with destiny.
I crazy.
Uh,
he's a big guy.
He's,
he,
he and Tony,
uh,
are,
are very similar in size.
And then you have Paul Tudor Jones.
You have some of the most sophisticated traders and financial minds who have
worked with Tony for 10 to 20 years.
And that's on an ongoing coaching basis because he does have very discreet,
very tactical,
uh,
exercises and tools that help you to find blind spots and fully leveraged things
that you're good at and so on.
So it's,
uh,
it's not easy.
It's not comfortable.
But,
uh,
certainly I've been,
I've been very,
uh,
benefited by the time that I've spent considering these things.
I'm biased because,
uh,
in high school I read unlimited power by Tony,
which had an impact.
I then when I got out of college and had my first job and I was commuting in my
piece of shit minivan,
this the green machine,
which was just I aid to complete disaster of car,
but I was trapped on one oh one in the bay area for people who know,
just bumper to bumper in rush hour to and from a mountain viewed as to San Jose
to work.
And I would listen to this used set.
I couldn't afford the full set a new copies.
So I had personal power too.
And cassette tape and listen to that,
which helped get me to the point where I started my first company.
And uh,
so Tony's made these appearances at very opportune moments in my life and you
know,
he's,
he's not,
he,
like I said,
I don't go to him for all things.
I don't think Tony as the answer to everything but with particular types of
selfimposed narratives and handicaps that you have built yourself or walls
around certain types of thinking or certain types of emotions that perhaps
served you very well in the past but no longer serve you.
He is exceptionally good at helping you work through all of that.
Yeah,
I just love that this whole genre,
like the self help genre is becoming like it,
it's not,
is frowned upon is it used to be like,
I don't know if you remember,
but probably you know 10 1520 years ago like if you went to that area of like
the bookstore,
you were like,
oh look at it.
Like who's in the self help section?
Like,
they must,
there must be something wrong with them and now,
now don't seriously,
they used to be the case and now it's like it's gone and he's probably at the
center of it.
But it's become this idea of not settling self help is,
is really is just like this idea that we're all on a journey of lifelong
learning and we all are done be asking ourselves and there's not a single person
that has all of life figured out.
So why don't we all actively openly work on this together and I think it's
awesome.
Yeah.
And I should also say that at one point,
as an example,
I was interviewed on the BBC and uh,
they wanted to talk about self,
this self help genre and I knew it was going to be a setup,
right?
I,
I knew that they wanted me to defend self help and they wanted to attack self
help,
right?
So and I knew this going in that this is what it was going to be.
Or I figured it out about an hour beforehand when I got some notes and I was
like,
oh,
I see where this is going.
So they,
they bring me out.
This is,
this is a television show and they say,
good evening,
Mr Ferris,
we just wanted to talk about Dah,
Dah,
bio,
blah blah blah.
What is your general opinion of the self help genre or something along those
lines?
And in effect I said,
I think 99.9% of it is just horse shit.
And I said,
it's,
it pains me sometimes to be associated with the label self help,
uh,
for x,
Y and z reasons.
And then the,
they didn't have a leg to stand on,
right?
Because I'd taken their side of the argument,
which kind of hilarious and a and then I said,
but at the same time I think the label self help has in many cases and unfairly
negative connotation because a,
if you look at almost any type of reading,
whether it's a novel where people want to escape or it's nonfiction,
where they're hoping to learn more about,
let's just call it Andrew Carnegie or you name the figure there is,
there is some motive behind that that they hope to help them.
Whether it's a shift of emotion,
the gathering of knowledge they can impress people at a dinner party or
otherwise.
And that if I were to look at who I would say potentially emulate in the world
of self help,
it would probably be be someone like,
this is a name you brought up earlier,
Ben Franklin,
Ryan,
who most certainly uh,
wrote extensively about what we would consider today self help.
But he's not lumped into the category of say potential.
And these people do exist,
certainly charlatans who are just selling a bill of goods that doesn't deliver
right.
There are plenty of people who have not walked the walk and talk extensively
about their expertise and make recommendations and prescriptions.
There are people all over the world in every possible discipline who do this.
And a lot of them tend to concentrate in this section of the bookstore called
self help,
unfortunately.
But it's,
it's that alone isn't enough to disqualify something.
And certainly if we look at these,
the popularity of tutorials on Youtube for instance,
of any possible subject matter,
if you look at the popularity of the creative lives in the Coursera is and so
on,
sure.
Uh,
everyone now has access to expertise that even 10 years ago would have cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars to access if they had the ability at all.
You look at say,
Harvard,
Mit,
Stanford,
many of these schools that are putting,
uh,
their courses online in some cases for free access.
And I know people who have taught themselves to code in this way.
All of that is self help,
right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's important I think that people not a disqualify exploring certain realms
because of a label that really represents a concept which may or may not apply
to what it is you're examining.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's going to be scammers in every genre too.
Yeah.
I love it.
I love how you,
Joe Rogan,
I don't know if you've seen these boats that he's done recently,
but he does videos of these martial,
the legitimate fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Joe Rogan puts up these fake martial arts videos.
I mean,
they're not fake.
They're videos of people who actually believe that what's happening is
happening.
But yeah,
these,
these like martial arts masters,
self-described throwing people across the room with their ci explosions and so
on,
and his caption usually legit as fuck or Hashtag that shit is fucking good.
Yeah,
there's a lot of nonsense out there.
But,
uh,
it doesn't mean that everything within a certain category is nonsense.
And it doesn't mean you should spend your entire life filtering for the 1%.
But also there are ways that you can assess the validity of different paths.
And quite frankly,
I would recommend for those people who haven't,
well,
I'll give you two recommendations.
So one is you can look at the back of the four hour body if you already have it.
There's an appendix,
which is effectively how to spot bad science and it will help you to not trick
yourself and also to get better at,
uh,
avoiding being tricked.
Uh,
so that's,
that's one recommendation.
And,
and not to seem like I'm selling my own book,
the excerpts for that appendix are from a book called bad science by a doctor
named Ben Goldacre,
which is absolutely fantastic.
So if you just want to be literate and better able,
scientifically literate,
or better able to separate the signal from the noise with the delusion of
information that we are assaulted by every day,
I would highly recommend that you check out one or two,
one or both of those resources.
You know,
I was going to ask you,
um,
tools of titans.
I mean,
obviously in your books there have been tons of book recommendations.
Yeah.
And there was that one kid.
Do you remember the kid that took all and he,
he'd created out all the books out of your recommendations have been random,
uh,
Yay.
Ranked him or just organize them as thumbnails.
Yeah,
I do remember that.
Yeah.
So the idea was that what is the most recommended book inside tool tools of
titans across the board?
Yeah.
All the people that were,
that were in that book and it kind of stack ranking them based on the votes.
Do you have that list anywhere?
Do you have a list of like the most recommended books by all of your guests?
Yeah,
I do actually.
And I'll pull it,
I'll pull it up right now because I put it off.
I put it on the blog for,
for everybody.
It's a great way.
Yeah,
I put it up,
but that's a great way to cut through all the crap,
you know.
Yeah.
I put it up on the blog and if you give me a second,
I will find where it is.
Uh,
this might take a second.
So I'm looking at tribe of mentors,
the most recent,
uh,
but the one,
where would I find this?
If you go onto tim.blog and search like tools of titans books,
we can put a link in the show notes,
right?
Put a link in the show notes.
So if you want a link,
this will be the smarter way to do it.
If you want to see a page where the most commonly recommended books from tools
of titans and from tribe of mentors combined,
you're looking at about 500 different world class performers of all different
disciplines,
ranging from top professional athletes to chess prodigies to former generals,
uh,
certainly 12 plus billionaires.
Uh,
then you will get to see rank ordered in terms of frequency,
which books are most recommended.
So I will put those in the show notes and you guys can find that at Tim dot.
Blog slash podcast if you want to see of these people who are the best at what
they do,
which books across disciplines do they recommend?
Most often?
A few of them just off the bat for people who are curious,
uh,
man's search for meaning by Viktor Frankl,
a poor Charlie's Almanack by Charlie monger seeking wisdom by Peter beveling.
Uh,
and,
uh,
certainly atlas shrugged,
even though it's a controversial book,
but I in rand comes up a lot in terms of developing a sense of personal agency.
I think that has popped up quite a lot and many more.
But I'll,
I'll give you the full list because there are some that pop up quite frequently,
uh,
that you won't recognize it all.
And those are to me oftentimes the,
the,
the really fun ones to explore.
Awesome.
Yeah,
I've got a bunch of audible credits waiting to be spent,
so I'll do that.
Awesome man.
Well,
I think that,
uh,
this is,
this is a solid ketchup.
Yeah.
Thanks for having me on.
And uh,
he has fun to chat.
And where,
where can people learn more about Kevin Rose?
Find you on the interwebs.
Certainly.
I'm,
my podcast is available@kevinrose.com.
Um,
and then also if you want to check out my free meditation APP,
it's 100% free.
I'm little bit more traditional meditation.
It's called Oak.
And you can do that.
Oak meditation.com.
Nice and succinct.
No social.
Ah,
I don't,
you know,
Twitter at [inaudible].
Kevin Rose,
but like,
I don't know that I use it that much anymore.
I'm more newsletter guy.
If you go to my website,
if you sign up for my newsletter,
I do a once a month newsletter and that's,
that's kind of what I use.
It's a good newsletter.
I subscribe to it,
which I can't say for many.
And yeah,
Twitter's,
Twitter's turned into a bit of a nasty neighborhood,
uh,
on most days.
You just feel it,
your mind in your business whistling,
walking down the street,
and then you have people throwing potted plants at your head and then Facebook's
the whole shit show.
So it's like that's the worst kind of show
what to do.
Go back to the tried and true Instagram,
Instagram or email.
Yeah.
All right,
my man,
uh,
well there's so much for taking the time and uh,
hope to see you soon.
Come,
come,
come visit Austin.
Got a barrel sauna waiting for you.
Awesome.
All right,
man.
See Ya.
Everybody listening or watching on the Youtubes,
uh,
you can find links to everything that we've talked about in the show notes,
Tim.
Dot.
Blog,
forward,
slash,
podcast,
and until next time,
be safe.
Do not take math for fun.
Uh,
follow professional advice with anything medically related and,
uh,
live the examined life.
Just because it is self help doesn't mean it can't help you.
So I will leave with that.